our multinational starting to feel the
heat at a meeting at the Parliament any
piece of the special committee on tax
rulings were primed and ready to take a
bite out of Apple and Google when small
and medium-sized enterprises have a tax
burden that are thirty percent higher
than most national corporations then
there's something wrong in the system
across the EU investigations are ongoing
to get companies to cough up for unpaid
taxes year-on-year EU countries lose one
point one trillion euros through
corporate tax avoidance but what
multinationals do isn't illegal they
simply make use of national tax
incentives to deal with the question how
responsible are us multinational company
earning billions and billions in the
European Union for the infrastructure we
need and the European Union for the
texts we need to pay all the things
people need to live here I cannot see
any feeling of responsibility for this
all I hear is the others are doing like
this so we do it too well Google and
Apple try to give a wrong impression
about that text behavior they were
quoting they are paying globally a fair
share of text which is true because they
pay taxes on the profits they book to
the US but Europe basically is left
without a proper tax base and about that
fact they were not ready to speak open
or the Parliament is ramping up the
pressure on companies to disclose their
earnings and the amount of tax paid in
every EU country that they operate in an
anti tax avoidance package is set to be
rolled out in April but any legislative
changes to close tax loopholes
ultimately lies in the hands of the very
member states that multinationals made
the deals with